I have to draw whenever I see
something beautiful.
What? Well...
Annihilation of an entire race
shouldn't be the price of peace.
Killing you was the point.
What the hell did you just say?
Hello. How are you? I'm Pepe Vilchis.
I'm a voice actor.
I'm Mexican, and I live in Mexico City.
Oh, boy.
This might turn into something incredible.
I started dubbing
just around the year of 1989.
The Godmother, as we call her,
Gloria Rocha, gave me my first shot.
She is the director of this TV show
you all know, called DRAGON BALL.
Later came another show.
You know it, too, KNIGHTS OF THE ZODIAC.
And that's how my career
as a voice actor began.
My family.
I am Trevor Belmont
of the House of Belmont.
And dying has never frightened me.
That's a great question.
What do the fans mean to me?
A huge commitment, really.
I appreciate them so much.
And for them to acknowledge my work
means everything to me.
So it becomes a huge commitment
to always give them my best effort,
all my affection,
and the work you're all used to.
So, what could I say? Thank you so much,
sincerely, for appreciating my work,
and all I can promise is my work,
to give my best, as always, for you all.
They can't even fight
their violent impulses. How foolish.
I must confess, I'm…
a huge videogames fan,
so one of my favorite shows
on Netflix
is THE WITCHER. It is excellent.
The characters are amazing.
It's a show I watch often.
Also, I was born in 1977, picture that…
The '80s and '90s where a hit for me,
because I grew up then,
and the COBRA KAI show…
I am so hooked, so please…
Please, don't take too long
with the new season.
Thank you.
I finished delivering my share.
Why don't you come over and have dinner?
Thank you so much for following the work
of Pepe Vilchis, that is, me.
It's wonderful. It's amazing, really,
to be here for all of you.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
If you'd like to follow my social media,
it's P, as in Pepe, another P, as in Pepe,
Vilchis, MX.
You'll find me on Instagram, on Facebook,
on Twitter, or even on my YouTube channel.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
I hope you're well, and…
Something I always say that
has helped me is, "Believe in love".
And never give up on your dreams.